la vidéo c'est comme ça la levée ou 2016
dans les environs de joliette
mario dénommé transporte une patiente
souffrant d'une hémorragie cérébrale en
route vers montréal un automobiliste
bloc soudainement le passage de son
ambulance
des projets au niveau des perceptions
calicoba pour que compensé
puis on avait monté un plan de
continuation après plusieurs minutes de
manoeuvre dangereuse
l'automobiliste cède finalement le
passage
[Musique]
c'est un cas extrême où des conséquences
aussi belle si elle peut dormir
une situation qui est rare mais il a vu
des automobilistes faire la course
suivre de beaucoup trop près et ignorer
le couloir de sécurité pour ça qu'on est
tous élocution apportiez si la plupart
des conducteurs respectent l'obligation
de céder le passage aux véhicules
d'urgence
nous avons constaté en accompagnant
jérémy la chance sur les lieux d'un
accident qu'il reste encore de la
sensibilisation à faire je veux pas non
plus elle est poussée le lan à tomber
verte mais les jeunes on est en pole est
là il regarde ton et sa main en
attendant tf1 soit on arrive il se rend
compte qu'on est l'eau en montérégie
les ambulanciers paramédicaux que nous
avons rencontré vivent une autre réalité
soit celle de l'heure de pointe du soir
oui d'accord de conduits
sur l'évolution circulation étaient des
gens savent pas trop où aller parce que
justement sont coincés pour eux comme
pour tous leurs collègues au québec
l'important c'est de transporter le
patient le plus rapidement possible à
l'hôpital et dans les conditions les
plus sécuritaires
mais le comportement de certains
automobilistes peuvent venir compliquer
le travail et ajouter un stress aux
patients qui ont sans doute pourrait
bien s'en passer
souvent les gens ont tout les réflexes
de freiner je sais pas pourquoi c'est
vraiment un réflexe d' analyse les gens
nous voient puis tout ce qu'on fait
l'effet surprise enfants lorsque vous
circulez près d'un véhicule d'urgence
vous devez faciliter son passage
la société de l'assurance automobile du
québec rappelle que les automobilistes
ont l'obligation de céder le passage aux
véhicules d'urgence dont les signaux
lumineux ou sonores sont activés
les ambulanciers paramédicaux sont aussi
confrontés au manque de civisme de
certains automobilistes
il était complètement la voie de droite
il y avait un véhicule en avant nous à
la lumière pour signaler à
l'intersection qu'on veut forcer on
avait laissé l'automobiliste en avant
nous nous a fait un doigt d'honneur et à
jamais
c'est cette note laissée par un citoyen
l'été dernier est un autre exemple des
patience et des compréhensions ça nous
arrive vraiment souvent fait souvent on
est soit les gens essaient de nous
suivre de proches ou de prendre la ligne
juste après nous quand on est en urgence
des fois c'est on essaie de se placer le
casse pot nuon des fois c'est pas
évident de trouver la meilleure place
puis oui des fois on bloque des gens que
les gens ils sont impatients comprennent
pas des fois que c'est urgent tout ça
peut sauver une vie
jérémy la chance lance cet appel aux
automobilistes
c'était un de nos proches qu'il était à
l'adresse on aimera cyclable en soit
plus le plus près par ce puits que dit
que les gens comprennent mais je pense
pour se mettre à la place du bassin de
la famille difficile
eric nos phrases au canada montréal